[Music]
man
black people the
Insurrection
racism what up yo I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Ruben report it's November 8th 2023
we're live streaming on Rumble locals
and YouTube we did not get kicked off
YouTube yesterday very exciting uh if
you haven't subscribed wherever you
watch please do so you have a at least a
fighting chance of getting getting our
videos uh as always there's a postgame
show at Ruben report. locals.com and in
case you're wondering what that very
quick cold open was that was
representative congresswoman Corey Bush
who is a member of the Hamas caucus and
yesterday Rashida Talib who I would say
is the leader of the Hamas caucus well I
would say she's the most committed to
the cause AOC is probably the leader you
know she's like the Cobra Commander of
the Hamas caucus Rashida Talib is like
doing a lot of the Dirty Work so she's
more of the Destro of the thing if you
guys can join me on a little uh G.I Joe
uh metaphor uh anyway Rashida was
censured yesterday by Congress yes
something actually good happened uh it
is my belief that Rashida Talib is a
Hamas supporter she is a terrorist
sympathizer I don't think she likes
America I think she would gladly undo
America just like AOC and Corey Bush and
ilhan Omar and the rest of them uh so
that's what we're going to start with
today the centure of Rashida Talib and
why she got censured and why it's
actually good that she got censured and
what it actually means uh and then of
course we'll show you some of the
hysterics that happened on the house
floor Corey Bush and others when it did
happen uh and then in about 15 minutes
from now you know yesterday I mentioned
that Jim Jordan had this uh this
bombshell yesterday or two days ago
actually that government has been
colluding with big Tech to censor all
sorts of people now we've we've known
this to certain degrees but now he's got
like docks he's got a whole bunch of
files and and direct emails showing how
big Tech colluded directly with the
government the government said hey we
don't like these people you got to
silence these people he sent out that
long Twitter thread if you watch the
show yesterday we covered that I was
included as one of the people that they
hit on that and I said that I wanted to
talk to Har meet Dylan because she is
one of if not the premier First
Amendment lawyers in the United States
and what I am curious discussed it with
her once or twice but I really want to
whittle it down now uh what are your
what is your recourse as a citizen in
the United States when we now have
factual information that the government
has trampled on your first amendment
rights do you do you get some cash do
you get somebody to show up at your door
and say I'm from the government and I'm
sorry uh I don't know we'll find out
that so harid will be joining us in
about 15 and then of course you know the
uh the third Republican debate is
tonight in Miami so I will be there
tonight we also will be doing a post
game show live from Miami we're going to
do I'm going to go to the debate and
then I'm going to leave a little bit
early so I can get back here and we're
going to do a night version of the show
we're going to darken the studio maybe
some dark LEDs maybe some tequila we
shall see what happens uh anyway all
that and more on the show today let's
talk about gravity to Fire and then
we'll get to it guys I want to tell you
about something that's been making my
days a whole lot easier gravity def
shoes these shoes are something else
guys I mean I'm always a fan of
comfortable Footwear you can tell that
about me but these shoes take it to a
whole new level more than just shoes
they're basically clouds for your feet
I'm not joking in a double blind study
by Olive View UCLA Medical Center and
published in the Journal of the American
podiatric Medical Association
participants experienced 85% less knee
pain it's the most powerful shock
absorption system put into a shoe
gravity to fire has this patented Verso
shock technology it's like a mini
trampoline in your shoes whether you're
strolling through the park running
errands or even just lounging at home
these shoes have got your back well I
should say your feet even better they're
stylish you get both comfort and style
that looks good and feels great so
here's the deal this gravity to fire
offer is exclusive to the Ruben report
head over to
gy.com that's
gy.com use the promo code Ruben 20 a
check out and get an extra $20 off your
first order this is uh $20 discount as a
thank you from Gravity to fire for being
with us today why not treat your feet to
some well-deserved Comfort check out
gd.com use promo code ruben2 and give
your feet the love they need all right
now back to me so yes a good day in
Congress Congress actually did something
for the American people they voted to
censure Rashida T and as long as I live
in this country with my ability to tell
you what I think and get out there and
fight for what I believe in I have no
problem telling you that I believe she
is a Hamas supporter I believe she
believes that terrorism is a legitimate
means to get whatever ends that she
wants I think she would gladly import
all of that stuff here I don't think she
likes the United States of America I
think she's bad news am I being clear
about what I think about this woman we
kind of got it uh anyway uh you might be
saying Dave that's a little bit
overboard I mean she's not so bad is she
uh well there was a series of things
that have happened a series of tweets uh
and videos that she has posted since the
the horrific attacks in Israel on
October 7th uh that got her into hot
water but the one that seems to have
pushed it over the edge that led to the
censure vote uh was this one directly
going after President Biden and ex well
just take a look we stand with
[Music]
Israel
Mr President the American people are not
with you on this
[Music]
one innocent civilians are going to be
hurt going forward I wish I could tell
you something different I wish that that
wasn't going to happen uh but it is it
is going to happen I want to thank
President Biden for his unequivocal
[Music]
support
we will remember in
[Music]
2024 all right so she's basically
threatening the president of the United
States my pen almost ran out of Inc as I
was writing down all of the nonsense in
there but before I share my opinions on
this why don't I share a bit from the
House of Representatives who explained
in a letter explained why they were
censuring her in the first place uh her
use of the word resistance in her
statement on the Hamas attack where she
argued that the suffocating dehumanizing
conditions in the Palestinian
territories could lead to resistance her
claimed that Israel bombed a hospital in
Gaza despite contradictory evidence she
later acknowledge that the Gaza Health
ministry's claims were in doubt and
called for an independent investigation
her use of the slow from The River To
The Sea a slogan that many view as
anti-semitic but it is viewed as a call
for freedom and equality uh by many
Palestinians uh okay so look The River
To The Sea thing let's just do that
quick you've got the river you've got
the sea you know what's right in between
those two things it's Israel so when you
call Palestine will be free from The
River To The Sea you were talking about
wiping out Israel that's about 8 million
Jews you got about 2 million Muslim
Arabs who are are very happy actually to
be citizens of Israel and fight in the
army and have equal rights and all of
that uh so she knows damn well she's
calling for genocide while she is
accusing Israel of committing genocide
uh which of course is absolutely absurd
because if you look at the last 50 years
of Gaza the population of Gaza has
basically 5x right so five times it's
gone up not not it didn't double or
triple five times uh so that is not a
genocide also it is very sad that well
according to the Gaza Health Ministry
10,000 people have been killed that I
mean that's taking Hamas word for it but
let's just say 10,000 people have been
killed first off a huge amount of them
are Fighters and Hamas supporters and
and all of those things on top of the
fact that they still have 200 uh
hostages including babies and elderly
people Holocaust Survivors and
everything else on top of the atrocities
they committed like every state has a
right to defend its citizens uh and not
only a right I would say actually a duty
uh but Hamas of course uses these people
as human Shields they put these people
in hospitals she lied about the hospital
bomb by the way there's a hospital in
Israel in Nash do that's been bombed
three times somehow that doesn't make it
uh to the New York Times but in that
video so she's sort of threatening uh
President Biden that you know if you
don't do what we want what we want what
we the American people want it's not the
American people the American people by
and large uh are much brighter than she
is and much more decent than she is and
they do support Israel as they would
support any Western Nation defending
itself from a bunch of bloodthirsty
jihadists uh yes you can point to some
of these crazy rallies where they are
calling for Jihad and she's all for that
and they are calling for genocide and
everything else but did you notice that
when they show you the states when she
shows the little logo of the states and
Ohio what did it say under Ohio it said
uh no peace on Stolen land that's what
this is really about and I actually
think that that was intentional uh
because they think that America is
stolen land that is what they think that
is what they believe and they are trying
to undo all of the West so if you think
that what they think is oh well it's
just the Jews that aren't supposed to be
in the ancient land of Israel right and
then they'll wrap it up after that no
it's that the Americans are not supposed
to be in Ohio or Michigan or anywhere
else like that is what they are trying
to undo and she is just she is the
leader of the Hamas movement in the
United States full stop period end of
sentence but she's got some cohorts with
her here's ilhan Omar having a breakdown
on the floor after the center vote what
is true here is that every single one of
them has not acknowledged the fact that
Palestinians are dying in the tens of
thousands but we'll continue to say it
is us who are not acknowledging Humanity
Rashida will stand
strong movement will continue for
Liberation until every
s has the right gentleman from Maryland
is
recognized okay uh I made a mistake
actually that wasn't after the centure
that was right before so they were
debating the centure that's ilhan having
a contion about it um do you think that
that woman cares about
Americans have you ever shown have you
ever seen a video of her yelling with
that I mean it's all theater with these
people they're larpers they're live
action role players they they rehearse
these speeches their body language and
all of that stuff Have You Ever Seen Her
be so passionate about Americans or
American lives it's strange that she's
not screaming about the 12 we believe
it's 12 it's a little unclear still 12
American hostages that are being held by
Hamas and when she talks about the
liberation of the Palestinian people uh
what she means is the death of an awful
lot of Jews uh we did find one other
video uh this was I believe right after
this is we found this one this is a
Reuben report special of ilhan right
after that moment take a
look
for see what we did there yeah uh but
this not should not surprise any of us I
mean this is what these people have
brought to America imagine the gall of
ilhan Omar who was brought up in Somalia
which is a place filled with sectarian
violence where virtually nobody has
Liberty or Independence or any of those
things that she reports to care about
and she comes to this country to become
a congresswoman to un to upend all of
the goodness that we offered her uh if
you care for an interview with a much
much better Somali immigrant uh my
interview with Aon hery Ali who many of
you know who has come to this country to
be a freedom fighter and fight for
actual American values and individual
rights and all that I interviewed her in
uh in London at the r conference
uh that will be up uh I believe in a day
or two should be up that will be up on
Monday uh so stay tuned on that we shot
about 20 interviews so we're laying them
out over the course of the week uh
anyway ilhan is she's just no good she
is just no good and instead of and this
is what they do with everything as you
know instead of pointing to the bad
people oh you know on October 6th there
were no Jews or Israelis in Gaza they
could have done whatever they wanted
actually they had ton of money because
their leaders have all gotten Rich the
leaders of Hamas are worth about 11
billion dollars they nobody wanted that
land or anything then they decided to
kill all these people and kidnap them
kidnpped them and everything else but
instead of pointing to the people who
are the real problem here who have
caused all of this what is ilhan always
doing well she's usually blaming Maga
and white men uh you might remember this
a couple months ago I would say uh uh
our our country should be more
fearful um of of of white men across our
country because they are actually um
causing uh most of the deaths within
this
country we should be more fearful of
white men do you see how absolutely
brainn numbingly ridiculous identity
politics makes people she wants people
to be walking down the street afraid of
white men because they are white you
guys are white you don't scare me you
think you scare me these people are just
terrible you know that you know all of
that but speaking of terrible people
let's just run with that for just a
little bit Corey bush is another member
of the Hamas caucus she's sort of I
would say she's the dumbest of all of
them AOC like she's she's kind of like
an idiot but she's very calculating and
she knows how to use media so I put her
as the leader Rashida is like the most
committed and she's like a genuine
racist I'd put ilhan in that bucket Cory
bush is just like the extra one that
they were like could we just find an
idiot who could just like scream and
genu flect and swing her arms all over
the place and scre scam a bunch of stuff
that she has no idea what she's talking
about they were like yeah yeah we found
Cory Bush here she is of a lack of care
and a lack of understanding and a lack
of seeing the humanity of folks who look
like Rashida Talib it's outrageous that
my colleagues are blatantly blatantly
attempting to silence the only
Palestinian American representative
right here um it's outrageous but it's
not surprising and let me tell you it's
not surprising because this place is
where 1700 members of Congress this Ed
body enslave black people it's not
surprising because they thought it was
right it's not surprising because this
is a place where members continue to
claim that the Insurrection on the
capital just appear to look like a
normal tourist visit it's not surprising
because this is the place where our
black and brown staff members repeatedly
speak of experiencing racism and sexism
islamophobia get pushed off of elevators
xenophobia and more right here in this
workplace this is the place and let me
say this she Mourns for the 1400 isra
for the 10,000 and she will not
stop fire now and she takes the death
threats that you all send that that they
gent lady is no longer recognized the
gentleman from
Maryland the desire to save lives is
greater gentle gentlemen from Maryland
is recognized what I
said note that I don't have to scream
nor wave my arms nor thrash around my
head or have trouble breathing when I
tell you that that woman is a deeply
anti-American
anti-white bigot and buffoon see how
easy that was that was easy I don't even
know that I had a heartbeat during that
whole thing it was very very easy to do
but what these people do is overly emote
and they act again
LARPing liveaction role playing they are
pretending to believe any of the things
that they said nobody cares that Rashida
Talib is Palestinian it's because she
supports Hamas and if she really cared
about the Palestinian people she would
want them liberated from Hamas again
Israel has not had a citizen in Gaza
since 2005 the entire world would have
loved that place to turn into the second
great place uh on the Mediterranean
Coast right there with Tel Aviv just
miles south
right and thrown it in the Jews face see
we made a place even nicer than Tel Aviv
they could have done it they could have
done it but instead they literally took
pipes that were sent to them to build
water infrastructure under the ground
and they turned it into Rockets So thus
when you have to defend bad ideas and
bad people you have to scream and you
have to thrash around and go completely
berserk the other thing you have to do
also is shed crocodile tears
so here's Rashida herself and
anti-Semitism makes us all less safe and
worri that your own child might suffer
the hores that six-year-old W did in
Illinois I can't believe I have to say
this but Palestinian people are not
disposable
we are human
beings just like anyone else my city my
grandmother like all
Palestinians just wants to live her life
with freedom and human dignity we all
deserve speaking up to save lives Mr
chair no matter Faith No Matter
ethnicity should not be controversial in
this chamber the cries of the
Palestinian and CH pal inian and Israeli
Children sound no different to me why
what I don't understand is why the cries
of Palestinians sound different to you
all we cannot lose our shared Humanity
Mr
chair the shared Humanity where is the
shared Humanity I mean it's
just oh thank you it's just cuz Rashida
she loves everybody you know what I mean
it's those white people that hate every
they hate everybody and and Rashid is a
good woman
and you get extra guacamole today that
was good that was good anyway her
crocodile tears The Psychotic screaming
of those other two and a couple of their
other friends it did not work because
yes she was censured here is New House
Majority Leader Mike Johnson officially
announcing that it has passed on this
vote the Y's are
234 and the Nays are 188 with four
answering present the resolution is
[Music]
adopted without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table for okay
so yes it happened she will be removed
from a couple of her positions which
that is good this person should be
ignored and and
if you are a Democrat if there are any
Democrats watching this if you are a
Democrat you should not want these
people in your party the inmates are
running the Asylum and there might be a
way to restore a decent Democrat Party
right there might be a way to revert the
Democrat Party back to a JFK type
Democrat Party or even a even a hey I
don't know maybe a Bill Clinton Democrat
type party uh it's a damn shame that
they got rid of Robert F Kennedy who's
now an independent because he saw that
the whole that the writing was on the
wall and the inmates were running the
Asylum and all that stuff there might be
a way to make it so that the Democrats
aren't completely psychotic and racist
and want to destroy the United States of
America but if there is it's on you guys
the Democrats because I ain't no
Democrat it's on you guys to figure out
what you are going to do with these
people because trust me this is not
about the Jews and it ain't about Israel
what this is about ultimately is
destroying the United States of America
and the they are in the house right the
Killer is calling from upstairs and his
name is Rashida
all right we're going to get to harm
meat and this whole uh fraus around uh
the government and big Tech silencing
little old Dave ruin and a couple other
people uh but before we do let me tell
you about start mail guys are you tired
of being targeted with fishing emails
fed up with Spam cluttering your inbox
concerned about companies like Google or
the government spying on your private
conversations then it's time to switch
to start mail start mail is a secure
alternative to Gmail that lets you send
emails like they're in a sealed
envelope excuse me making sure your
communication stays private and secure
services like Google collect your data
and use it for targeted ads startmail is
a strictly adree service that does not
collect or share any data with third
parties with third parties for
advertisement or tracking your startmail
account comes with all the features you
need including unlimited disposable
email addresses to protect your inbox
from fishing scams and hacking attempts
switching to start mail is super easy if
you're worried about your old email
stored on Gmail Outlook Yahoo and more
they've got you covered start mail's
hassle-free migration tool lets you move
your emails and contacts with just a
couple clicks no technical knowledge
required over the past decade startmail
has become a trusted name in email
privacy so why wait any longer switch to
startmail and experience the peace of
mind that comes with a truly secure
email service sign up today and save 50%
on your first subscription year go to
startmail.com dve and join millions of
people who are moving away from Big Tech
to secure email providers that start
mail with the tea /ve and that is a
perfect Advertiser for the segue into
big Tech censorship so very quickly
before I bring on uh First Amendment
lawyer harmit Dylan I want to just recap
what Jim Jordan revealed two days ago
here's a shorter version of his Twitter
thread bombshell report on the
censorship industrial complex hundreds
of secret reports show how that the DHS
gov and cisa gov which is cyber security
and infrastructure Security Agency and
the gec which is the state department
Stanford University and others work
together to censor Americans before the
2020 election including true information
jokes and opinions the federal
government disinformation experts
experts over at University's big Tech
and others worked together through
election through the election Integrity
partnership to Monitor and censor
American speech according to one e EIP
member the EIP was created at the
request of sisa the head head of the EIP
also said that the EIP was created after
working on some modering ideas with cisa
here's how it worked EIP stakeholders
including the federal government would
submit misinformation reports EIP would
analyze the report and find similar
content across platforms EIP would
submit the report to Big Tech often with
a recommendation on how to censor the
Judiciary GOP and weaponization uh
that's the weaponization of government
Department obtained these non public
documents and information from Stanford
only after the threat of contempt uh of
Court who was targeted Americans of all
political Stripes but especially
conservatives and here's just a couple
Donald Trump nuke inrich Mike Huckabee
Sean Hannity harit Dylan that's PN g-
ban that's har meet uh Charlie Kirk etc
etc and yes it didn't stop there even
went after Newsmax Ruben report I can't
believe it I like that guy James O'Keefe
uh and uh he finished up by saying what
speech was targeted for censorship true
information jokes and political
opinions excuse me so with no further
Ado allow me to bring on the founder of
the Dylan Law Group the former candidate
for the RNC chair against R McDonald uh
and McDaniel and unfortunately that
didn't work out the results last night
are proof of that harit Dylan how are
you I'm great thanks for having me here
Dave harit I should also mention before
we start so I can cough for a second you
also live in San Francisco which I find
so absolutely bizarre but you're just
trying to fight the good fight there
still huh this is the jurisdiction
actually for fighting big Tech and
that's one reason why I haven't moved
away is the courthouse is close to my
office fair enough all right so let's
dive into the specifics on this
obviously you you've been on the show uh
many times we've talked about First
Amendment issues related to Big Tech
you've sued Google before you're in the
midst of a bunch of lawsuits related to
all this but can you explain a bit or
can you unpack I guess a bit of what Jim
Jordan was talking about there
specifically and then of course I want
to talk about what are the the ways that
someone whose rights might have been
infringed could actually go after the
government well absolutely so what we
have seen in this interim report from
Jim Jordan is a fascinating set of
additional pieces of a mosaic but this
picture started to emerge actually back
in 2021 very soon after the election
and what we found there is a Judicial
Watch first did some work regarding um
public records requests from from
California and we found in
California that the National Association
of secretaries of state which is
featured in this uh report as well as U
money from taxpayers and the California
secretary of state was used to censor
speech in California where Twitter is
and other social media companies are
headquarters so we had to Center for
American Liberty mind nonprofit filed a
lawsuit over this back in 2021 and that
lawsuit has made its way up to the
courts through up to the Supreme Court
where we're sitting right now waiting
for search so in the ninth circuit where
I live and where I practice the courts
have not recognized a claim by a citizen
who was censored on social media at the
beest of the government to Sue and
recover any relief but on the other hand
in Missouri the secretary of state of
Missouri and other secretaries of State
Su the government more recently last
year on behalf of scientists including
my friend Jay baaria and others who were
censored on their truthful and
scientific speech about a host of issues
related to vaccines and the court
reached the opposite result there this
past summer in a very scathing opinion
saying that where the government tells
private parties social media companies
what they can and cannot say that is
viol ation of the First Amendment and so
now that case is also sitting in the
United States Supreme Court because the
Biden Administration has been fighting
for its right at the federal level to
censor your speech and now Along Comes
This report which is very interesting
from a legal perspective because what it
shows and this is legally relevant is
that the government was aware our
federal government was aware that it had
to hide its censorship activity it could
not openly say elections are unsafe we
have a right to come in there and shape
what you see because that's what
fascists do in banana republics that's
not what we do here in America it's
illegal in America so they knew what
they were doing was wrong and they used
proxies like these puppets that they set
up in these pseudo scientific University
efforts in multiple universities with
Stanford and some others to censor your
speech and so they come up with these
pseudo scientific ways of analyzing
whether disinformation is spreading in
some kind of viral way they use the
actual terms of diseases to describe our
accurate commentary and in my case the
example and of course this is an
incomplete report but the example that
Jim Jordan tweeted of my speech was
simply that I was talking to two of my
colleagues at my Law Firm on Election
Day in 2020 and saying hey I'm getting
reports from Pennsylvania that things
are going okay in parts of Pennsylvania
but they're a complete disaster in
Philadelphia
check check check all accurate and that
was somehow deemed to be unsafe speech
because I specifically called out the
Attorney General over there and
questioned what was going on there and
so um when you multiply this by
thousands of speakers and tweets and
comments that have been taken down we
know that the first amendment has been
violated now we are waiting with baited
breath for the United States Supreme
Court to fully decide this issue and if
they decided the way the ninth circuit
wanted then you have no rights and they
can go ahead and censor you
surreptitiously using proxies using by
the way universities where the same
students who are doing this work are
shouting uh the most vile things so
propaganda is coming from the very
places that the sensors are coming from
um so I think we're in a real Crossroads
here on the First Amendment the first of
our most important civil liberties in
this country today right and it should
be noted that even if whatever you were
saying or I was saying or Jay bachari
was saying was complete nonsense you
still have a right a First Amendment
right to share complete nonsense even
though that wasn't the case let's say in
the three of us but you do have a First
Amendment right to say crazy things I
mean look what look what I just showed
on the on the floor of the house from
yesterday um what do you what would you
want a proper recourse to be so let's
say these cases go in the direction that
you want them to go and they work their
way up to the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court actually rules boy uh
these people's First Amendment rights
were violated the government actually
went out of its way to create these sort
of banana agencies to silence people and
everything else like what what is the
win other than us seeing it because I
think that's what most people think at
this point we have sort of like farsal
Senate hearings and we expose a lot of
things but nothing tangibly ever
tangible ever comes out of this stuff
well so what we need is a injunction
from the Supreme Court endorsed by the
Supreme Court on the government using
proxy or itself telling regulated
entities social media companies what to
what they can show that is what is
needed but beyond that the reveal that
Jim Jordan showed us is very important
legally because nor and I I probably sue
the government more than any Republican
lawyer in America and what you learn in
the course of doing that is that unless
you can prove that a government official
did something wrong and that they knew
it was wrong and it was clearly
established to be wrong you cannot hold
that government official personally
liable for damages and so when we see
that the government actually went about
this in a syruptitious way which to me
clearly implies they knew that what they
were doing was prohibited by the first
amendment that allows you potentially to
pierce that qualified immunity Veil and
get damages from the individuals now are
they really going to pay it themselves
they are if they get identified by their
agencies but making real cash change
hands and also having Junctions and
having a federal judge who sets a
monitor whose job it is to monitor the
government agencies that have been doing
wrong and hold them accountable and make
them come into court hanging their heads
and describe what they've been doing to
fix the problem that is what is
necessary of course also attorney fees
paid to the attorneys who do the work to
expose these things right so if wait if
I understood you correctly though the
damages would be paid by the actual
people who did this not not the
government itself so it's basically some
like mid-level guy who is like yeah I
don't like Dave rubin's tweet on Co I'm
going to delete that and then I have to
go after that guy who you know makes
whatever he makes with his government
salary to to get anything and again I
don't I actually don't want money out of
this I want I want truth and I would
love actually a letter from the United
States government saying Dave yeah we
censored you and we're sorry like that
actually and we're not going to do it
again how about that that that might be
enough for me yeah absolutely so you
know the answer is that's right so
dating back to my clerkship in the
United States Department of Justice in
the early 90s I'm dating myself now
there really is uh very limited remedy
at the federal level for federal
violations of your civil rights uh there
used to be a common law cause of action
called vivons but the Supreme Court is
really Whitt that down I have spoken to
Jim Jordan and other members of Congress
I've testified in front of Congress
repeatedly what is needed is a social
media and media users Bill of Rights
that allows citizens a private right of
action to sue the federal government
hold the Federal Government liable for
damages and attorney fees and all of
that and punitive damages for violating
our first amendment and our other
important fundamental wellestablished
civil rights we don't have that and I'm
sorry to say that many republican
members of Congress like Democrats are
in the pockets of American corporations
including big Tech corporations they
want nothing more than to have their own
accounts you know free to say whatever
they want or get checks from these
companies many conservative
organizations are in the same boat as
well I I called out CPAC many years ago
for allowing Google to be a platinum
sponsor of CPAC at the same time that my
client James deore was fired from Google
for simply saying true things and so we
really had to get our act together in
this and understand that the corporation
worship of the 1970s 80s and 990s in the
Republican party it needs to stop and we
need to understand that corporations
today they're regulated I don't blame a
corporation where they federal
government is breeding down your neck
and the FTC has power over you and and
senators are threatening to take away
your uh Communications decency act
Community I don't blame them for paying
the paying the you know vigorish uh if
you will to be able to stay in business
so we have to protect them and protect
ourselves and that means people in
Congress need to step up and give
citizens rights because this is a
rampant expansive and unknown scope
problem at this time I I believe Jim
Jordan's tweet thread only scratches the
surface God knows what these people have
been doing right I always say it's not
the things that I know they're doing
with Shadow Banning and everything else
it's all of the things that we don't
know that I'm really worried about I I
want to jump to two clips with you and
then I want to discuss some some
election stuff because obviously
yesterday there was an election and you
did run for RNC chair and and I
supported you Des Santa supported you
had a ton of support uh but
unfortunately we got Rona McDaniel and
and clearly it ain't working out so
we'll get to that in just a sec but I
want to throw back back to this clip
from about 5 years ago and and I'm sure
most of my audience will remember this
this is when uh Twitter CEO Jack dorsy
and Twitter head of legal vagia Gade
were on Joe Rogan's show with Tim p and
it was obvious to many of us that there
was massive censorship we didn't know
that the government was directly
involved uh but CEO Jack dorsy and head
of legal so she was in charge of all of
the decision-making related to
censorship uh she was getting grilled by
Tim p on Rogan take
one really important thing that needs to
be stated is that Twitter by definition
is a biased platform in favor of the
left period it's not it's not a question
I understand you might have your own
interpretation but it's very simple
conservatives do not agree with you on
the definition of misgendering if you
have a rule in place that specifically
adheres to the left ideology You by
default are enforcing rules from a
biased perspective well Tim there are a
lot of people on the left who don't
agree with how we're doing our job
either for sure and those people think
that we don't take enough action on
abuse and harassment and we let far too
much Behavior go
but that's a radical example though I
mean what he's talking about I mean in
terms of generalities that in general
things lean far more left would you
agree to that I don't know what that
means but in this particular case it's
how the speech is being used this is a
new Vector of attack that people have
felt that I don't want to be on this
platform anymore because I'm being
harassed and abused and I need to get
the hell out so of course Tim P was
right and we now know that vayia and uh
what's Jack dorsy they are no longer at
Twitter Elon got rid of them very
quickly we'll get to a video of Elon on
Rogan last week in just a sec uh but
when you when you watch that in
retrospect it's like man she was
basically an agent of the government and
Jack dorsy by the way who said even in a
in a tweet to me that we do not shadow
shadow ban at Twitter I was then at
Twitter six months ago and they showed
me under the hood the entire system that
they have there was designed to Shadow
band so I suppose none of this surprises
you in retrospect not at all I mean look
like said I've been suing these
companies for longer than anybody I know
and I was on a panel one time way many
years ago with the head of litigation at
um at Facebook and he used almost The
Identical words that the J aade just
used I mean they actually these guys
talk to each other this has been their
party line well the left's not happy
with us either okay that's not an answer
to the problem and um you know what we
now know is that the censorship
industrial complex is way more vast and
pervasive and there are almost certainly
censorship activities ities that have
yet to be uncover and not not to mention
I I I read an alarming report this
morning about sock puppet accounts that
our government is using to spread
propaganda in foreign countries and
probably our own country and you know
there are a lot of things that Elon
hasn't had a chance yet to to deal with
so um none of that surprises me and none
of that answers for the government state
and federal governments pervasive
censorship of American citizens what
happened at the federal level is just
one part of it I describe to you the
lawsuit we filed at Center for americ
Liberty for Rogan oh Handley that was
California Secretary of State doing it
and many other state secretaries of
State have done that and they had their
own level of immunity which makes it
difficult to sue them in federal court
over Federal claims so it's a it's a
complicated situation all right so I
want to flash forward now to five and a
half years after that clip on Joe Rogan
to Joe Rogan's show last week so now he
had Elon on and here's Elon basically
saying that Twitter 1.0 run by those two
people we just showed you right there
was a government organization what was
that like is that to me that was the
most bizarre was the Twitter files when
you let shellenberger and Matt taibe and
all those guys get in the Twitter and
the response were Matt taibe gets
audited I mean which is just wild I mean
it's just so blatant and so in your face
yeah it's weird no I
mean the yeah the great which and and by
the way Jack didn't really know know
this but the degree to which Twitter was
simply um an arm of the government was
not well understood by the public and uh
it it was there was no it was whatever
the official government I it was like
prda basically um you know a state
publication is the way to think of old
Twitter it's a state publication and was
the justification from their perspective
that they are progressive liberals they
have the right intentions it's important
that they stay in power the progressive
liberals stay in government and power
because this is the this is their there
there was there was uh basically
oppression of
um any any views that would even I would
say be considered middle of the road um
but certainly any thing on the the right
I'm not talking about like like far
right I'm just talking mildly right the
people like Republicans were suppressed
at 10 times the rate of Democrats um now
that's because uh old Twitter was
fundamentally controlled by the far left
it was like completely controlled by the
the farle so harid I think most people
watching that they get it they now see
that uh Elon has done good with Twitter
I think there's still a huge amount of
problems there and you just mentioned
the sock puppet accounts I mean I'm
seeing more Bots and sock puppets it's
like it's absolutely insane there but
he's clearly trying yeah all of that
being said do you have hope that say
Facebook and Google and YouTube
YouTube's the number two search engine I
think Twitter is now sorry I think Tik
is now the number one search engine do
you have any hope that any of these
things could be reformed through the
government or or their on their own well
so not on their own and not through the
government and God forbid that our
freedom of speech hinges on the whims of
one billionaire much as we love he's
done with with Twitter but uh that
cannot be the situation and for years
like I said I've been pleading with
members of Congress who I have access to
do something about this you just need to
pass a law we could have done at the
beginning of the Trump administ rtion
they didn't do it and it needs to be
done and this is a bipartisan issue I do
not want our I don't want Republican
presidents and Republican governments
censoring the left either people have a
right to free speech in our country and
if you by the way if uh if Twitter is
proved up imagine what the New York
Times and Washington Post and the San
Francisco Chronicle and all these other
Rags what are they that so it's a it's a
poorly kept secret that what we see has
been heavily manipulated
by our government for many years and
citizens should have a right and a
private right of action believe me if
lawyers start filing lawsuits and real
money exchanges hands this will stop all
right well hopefully this is just the
beginning of some of this stuff being
exposed and then and then people like
Jim Jordan on the government side and
people like you on the legal side doing
something about it I want to shift for
just a couple minutes uh because as I
mentioned you did run for uh the head of
the RNC ra McDaniel won unfortunately
and yesterday we did have an election
and it did not go well for Republicans
once again I've got a little info here
from CBS Democrats scored victories in
several States in Tuesday's off-year
election Ohio voters will enshrine
abortion access in the state's
Constitution and Democratic incumbent
Governor Andy Basher won his reelection
in Kentucky CBS News projects two big
victories for Democrats as President
Biden faces daunting polls regarding his
reelection prospects in 2024 Democrats
also took control of Virginia's House of
delegates and retained their hold on the
majority in the state senate according
to the Associated Press and harit before
I have you jump in my friend Kurt sh
shikler who's been on the show many
times he wrote this on Twitter great
work GOP chairwoman that's Rona McDaniel
another defeat in her unbroken record of
failed election cycle a special shout
out to Donald Trump for his support for
her great work so it was an odd thing
because most of the base did not like ra
they liked you Donald Trump however
supported her Ronda santis supported you
so it had very very strange uh bed
fellows that was similar to the
speakership thing where the Bas seemed
to hate Kevin McCarthy but Trump was
into McCarthy what do you make of what's
going on with the Republican party at a
national level I am a Florida Republican
but at a national level I don't know
what to do with this party well so first
of all you have a great governor in
Florida and I I'm a I'm a fan of the
governor as a governor we'll gladly take
you over here we'll gladly take you he's
a great governor and I also represent
president Trump and his campaign in
multiple cases dozens of cases and so I
will choose my words very carefully um
yes I made a run for RNC chair I was
drafted by many members of the RNC who
believed that we needed to do things
differently to win elections and very
popular outside the RNC and the 168
members of the RNC in their wisdom they
chose to select the status quo so I
think if you have a beef with what
happened you should you know find out
how you're members of the RNC and your
state they're three in each state or
territory voted and give them a piece of
your mind because we have upcoming
leadership elections at the RNC now the
voters chose ra and I've you know
congratulated her and I'm doing
everything I can to support her I've
been called on very little over the last
uh year to do anything within the party
and so we're doing our work outside the
party what I tweeted this morning is
there is no Cavalry coming guys in the
states there's no federal RNC welfare
coming to bail you out the fact is that
the way we do elections in America has
changed and The Sweet Spot for all of us
who want to win elections is targeting
Republican or conservative or even
moderate leaning low propensity voters
and getting their ballots in by all
means necessary so people sitting behind
Twitter keyboards can sit on their butts
and talk about oh well first you need to
shut down the machines and X Y and Z I
mean in a perfect world I would have it
be paper ballots voting on Election Day
we aren't in a perfect world stat set
election laws get with the program and
figure out how to win elections when you
have our excellent candidate in Kentucky
outspent by more than three to one y um
it's literally the job of the Republican
Governor Association to raise that money
and spend it what happened there guys um
and then in other places
uh I I'm going to hear I'm sure some
Afterparty analysis about oh we need to
get our story straight on abortion and
what the messaging needs to be well the
RNC does pay tens of thousands of
dollars a month on you know Consulting
fees of communications officials that's
not really working out very well so
again everybody should figure out what
the message is that works in your
jurisdiction for your candidate for your
state you cannot hide from this issue we
have to embrace it and we have to have
thoughtful persuasive messaging on it
whatever that is and get out there and
figure it out and so that is my takeaway
the rnc's job is to elect a president
really and everything else that has been
piled on um we've been doing it but not
winning over the last few years states
have a responsibility and state parties
do so get off the Republican National
Committee welfare raise your own money
and get a paid Army of signature and
ballot gatherers out there to get things
done on ballot measures this is what the
left does the left is getting is plan is
for the bait to be abortion related uh
ballot measures in their states where's
our bait what is our bait it could be
transgender bands it could be so many
things that turn out our voters we
where's the money so I would say figure
it out and give local and act locally
there was one little nugget of decency
that came out of the elections last
night this is a tweet from Lee zeldon
who of course is unfortunately not
governor of New New York he's still a
representative up there suffi County
that's Long Island where I'm from just
elected its first GOP County Executive
in decades Ed Roma this is an enormous
flip of a Long Island suburb from Blue
to Red so it is nice to know that in the
place that I grew up there is a little
bit of Sanity uh harit I will give you
the last word are are you hopeful I mean
as we roll into this presidential
election and obviously you like both of
those guys and everything else are you
hopeful that maybe there can be some
reconciliation between those two camps
and that the Republicans will kind of
get their crap together so to speak I I
hope that uh Governor DeSantis supports
uh president Trump he's my choice for
president and I think that's the choice
of most uh Republican voters and we have
to sort of thread the needle here my
partners are flying around the country
from hearing to hearing defending the
right of uh president Trump to be on the
ballot which is um you know
extraordinary that that unelected judges
are substituting their their judgment
there so our Republic is at Great risk I
would not be sitting here doing this as
a volunteer Republican if I did not have
optimism but optimism untethered from
action and cash and hard work is is
meaningless so we really have to get out
there and do the hard work in the next
year we have a year and this is the most
important year in my political life
haret it's always a pleasure talking to
you and when I get that midlevel
bureaucrat to show up at my door with a
note that says we censored you I'm sorry
I'm going to send it to you so you can
sign it and then we'll then we'll frame
it how about that I love it absolutely
all right harit Dylan thanks so much and
guys yeah my pleasure uh guys as you
know tonight is the debate in my new
home of Miami here is the NBC News promo
for what's going to happen NBC News
hosts the Republican presidential debate
moderated by Lester Holt and Kristen
Welker joined by Hugh hwit how would the
candidates confront the critical
challenges at home and abroad as the
next commanderin-chief tomorrow at 8:00
p.m. God the theater of all this it's
like the orange man's not going to be
there he's going to be in haia which is
about I don't know 20 minutes or so
outside of Miami having a rally it's
like if there was ever a time it doesn't
matter who you're supporting right now
it really doesn't if there was ever a
Time relative to everything that's
happening in the world right now that we
needed to have a debate it doesn't
matter who's up by 50 or 40 or blah blah
blah it's like we should be having this
battle out out in front and uh and
everyone should be there defending their
ideas and unfortunately that's just not
where we're at so I don't have any great
illusions that something really
incredible is going to happen tonight I
do sense uh notwithstanding what harit
just said uh I do sense that there has
been a momentum shift in Iowa I mean
really think about what happened in Iowa
if Trump is supposedly up by 50 points
how does it make sense that Kim Reynolds
the super popular governor of Iowa who's
just she's just a gem uh that she's like
you know what I'm going to back the guy
down by 50 right because she's now
campaigning with d santis how would it
make sense politically for her future
for her career or anything else to go
against Trump to go against Maga do you
think maybe something different's
happening on the ground in Iowa and
maybe the mainstream media doesn't want
to cover that because maybe they think
Dan santis is more of the threat and
maybe they think Trump's negatives are
so high that he would be a great
candidate to go against the elderly man
pretending to be president do you think
any of that's possible or am I just
totally is you tell me we've got a
postgame show coming up in just moments
at Ruben report. locals.com also a
reminder our new show people of the
internet is streaming at every day
Monday through Thursday at 1 p.m. uh
we're doing that in conjunction with the
fine folks over at tenet media my full
interview from Arc with Eric Weinstein a
long awaited return to the Ruben report
uh is up right now and yes we will be
live in here perhaps with some tequila
and some dark lighting and glitter what
about some glitter no Glitter I've been
told no Glitter there is no Glitter uh
at 1000 p.m. Eastern tonight I thank you
for watching our cold clo is of that
elderly watch watch what happened this
is Biden yesterday just here we go all
right
goodbye
[Music]